rules restrictions and limits on our
freedom has been the way of life for 16
months
but in two weeks those rules will be
gone even if the virus is still going
strong
infections hospitalizations deaths on
the rise again
for the pm determined to carry on we
must be
honest with ourselves that if we can't
reopen
our society in the next few weeks then
we must ask ourselves when will we and
to those who say
we should delay again the alternative to
that
is to open up in winter when the virus
will have
an advantage or not at all this year
and major changes on the way we will
change the basic tools that we have used
to control human behavior will move away
from legal restrictions and allow people
to make their own
informed decisions about how to manage
the virus we will remove all legal
limits on the numbers meeting indoors
and outdoors we will allow all
businesses to reopen
including nightclubs we will end the one
metre plus rule on social distancing
and the legal obligation to wear a face
covering
all rules scrapped apart from the
requirement to self-isolate when unwell
but even without rules will have to keep
fighting
we are in the face of an increasing
epidemic at the moment and therefore we
need to behave accordingly in terms of
trying to limit
transmission spread prime minister you
promised a cautious but irreversible
route
out of lockdown and now you're about to
get rid of all restrictions of big bang
approach
i put it to you that many people will
see that not as cautious
but as reckless we are trying to move
from
a system of very elaborate government
rules to one in which we rely on people
to exercise personal responsibility i
don't want people to feel that this is
as it were the moment to get uh d mob
happy this is the end of the
of covid it is very far uh from the end
of
dealing with this virus you just don't
seem to be committing to irreversibility
either so is this cautious or
irreversible if we do
find another variant that doesn't
respond
to the to the vaccines then clearly we
will have to take whatever steps
we need to do to protect the public but
soon it will be down to the public to
protect themselves
some scientists concerned if we are to
do the things that keep us safe
we need good and clear messaging and i
think the moment
all the messaging is telling us well
look there isn't a problem at all here
indeed um getting rid of all
restrictions sends a very clear message
that there isn't a problem
and that in itself is going to affect
behaviour in a major way
and the labour leader opposed to the
pm's big bang approach
to throw off all protections at the same
time
when the infection rate is still going
up is reckless we need a
balanced approach we need to keep key
protections in place
in two weeks time the choices about how
to manage this virus will be left to you
government stepping out of our lives but
the virus still with us
whether politicians will have to step
back in the big unknown
beth rigby sky news westminster